ein Hinweis bevor es losgeht in diesem
Podcast werden unter anderem
Verstümmelungen und Kannibalismus
thematisiert denjenigen denen solche
Schilderungen zu nahe gehen raten wir
vom Hören ab
hallo mein Name ist Sky Duo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin und hier ist wie immer eure Natalie
Strauß und Marco Kasimir Liebe Natalie
ich fange gleich mal an weil mich dieser
Fall extrem mitgenommen hat ich meine in
dieser Reihe haben wir schon viele
grausame Sachen gehört aber beim
Nachlesen zu diesem Fall ey das ist mir
wirklich schon schwer dran zu bleiben
wie war das bei Dir
mir ging es genauso ich musste mehrmals
pausieren und mal ganz kurz sacken
lassen was ich da gerade wahrgenommen
habe weil dieser Typ ist ja echt
jenseits von Gut und Böse hier geht es
ja auch nicht um einen Fall sondern vor
Gericht verhandelt werden neun Morde 32
Mod Versuche drei Überfälle mindestens
ein Fall von Vergewaltigung und 27
Brandstiftung
eventuell sind das noch nicht mal alle
Verbrechen gewesen aber zumindest dieser
Anzahl an Kapitalverbrechen konnte man
Peter Kürten um den es heute geht
Anlassen ja am Ende wird das Gericht
Peter Kürten 1931 für 9 Morde und sieben
Mordversuche Vorurteilen aber der Weg zu
dieser spektakulären Verurteilung der
ist lang grausam und sehr sehr blutig
[Musik]
diese Geschichte beginnt vor 140 Jahren
im aufstrebenden deutschen Kaiserreich
Mülheim am Rhein ist 1883 eine boomende
Industriestadt die damals noch nicht zu
Köln gehört
Stahlwerke und Gießereien bestimmen die
Szenerie mit ihren schwarzen Schloten
dem unablässigen Lärm und den grauen
Massen an Arbeitern die täglich zum
Klang der werksirenen mit ihrer Schicht
beginnen
in dieses industrie-entfernung wird am
26 Mai 1883 Peter Kürten geboren er ist
der drittälteste Spross einer später 13
köpfigen geschwisterbande
der Vater ist zu der Zeit gerade 24
Jahre alt von Beruf sandformer er baut
die Gussformen für schwere
Maschinenteile
der Vater von Peter ist schwerer
Alkoholiker ein wüsterschläger dessen
Faust weder vor den Kindern noch vor
seiner Ehefrau Halt macht Peter Kürten
wird später über seinen Vater sagen ich
habe meinen Vater nie geliebt aber immer
gefürchtet ich habe meinen Vater schon
in frühester Jugend als sein ungeheuer
kennengelernt und es wurde uns dadurch
wenn die Mutter sagte dann oder dann
kommt der Vater einer heillose Angst
eingejagt
denn auch zahlreich waren seine Exzesse
die ich auch in frühester Jugend schon
miterlebt habe bestehend den
Zertrümmerung von Möbeln und
Misshandlung der Mutter und der
Gewalttätigkeiten gegen andere Menschen
und krakeelen und trinken und so weiter
zu dieser Zeit und in diesem Milieu ist
das leider nicht ungewöhnlich
später als Peter Kürten schon ein
Teenager ist vergewaltigt der Vater
seine älteste Tochter und geht dafür
auch ins Gefängnis
was für eine grausame Kindheit es wurde
auch berichtet dass sich die wachsende
geschwisterzahlen um Peter Kürten immer
fremdgeblieben ist die Kinder fanden in
dieser Brutalität also nicht zueinander
sondern wollten einfach nie zwischen die
Fronten geraten die Mutter hat zudem
nach einigen Geburten in ihrer
Verzweiflung versucht den Kindern das
dunkle los zu ersparen sie wickelte sie
nach Peter kürtens Erinnerung in kalte
nasse Tücher in der Hoffnung dass die
Säuglinge an unser Kühlung für immer
Einschlafen würden es gelang ihr
glücklicherweise nicht wobei zwei
geschwisterkürtens zeitig sterben also
wer weiß das ist echt heftig ich meine
wie grausam muss das alles gewesen sein
wenn eine Mutter solche Handlung gegen
ihre Kinder vornimmt wie groß ist die
Verzweiflung
Peter Kürten flieht schon als kleiner
Junge so oft es geht aus dieser Hölle er
treibt sich oft am Fluss herum mit acht
Jahren bleibt er das erste Mal für
mehrere Tage verschwunden schlägt sich
mit kleinen Diebstählen durch und zeigt
zudem schon äußerste Aggressivität
selbst
älteren Kinder gegenüber
er wird gefunden und zurückgebracht und
entkommt dabei nur knapp dem Kinderheim
zu dieser Zeit hat der Junge schon eine
Art Freundschaft zum
örtlichen Abdecker und Hundefänger
entwickelt er begleite diesen oft wenn
Streuner eingefangen und überzählige
Welpen ertränkt werden oder der Abdecker
Tiere anderweitig umbringt
auch die Schlachtung von Tieren reizt
den Jungen und verschafft ihm erste
Erregung
dann zieht die Familie 1894 nach
Düsseldorf die großen Fabriken hungern
nach Arbeitern Peter treibt sich nach
der Schule in den düsteren Hinterhöfen
und den rußgrauen Vorstädten herum
als früh pubertierender soll Peter dann
auch versucht haben ein Schaf zu
vergewaltigen als das nicht richtig
gelingen will schneidet er dem Tier die
Kehle durch und erlangt beim Geräusch
des herausströmenden Blutes einen
Orgasmus
aber all das liegt noch in einem
Schatten von niemandem groß beachtet
1899 begeht Peter Kürten dann seine
erste größere Straftat einen Diebstahl
darauf sollen noch mindestens 78 weitere
Straftaten folgen
um ehrlich zu sein wenn ich jetzt schon
ziemlich fertig ja all diese Aspekte ja
das Elternhaus der Umgang mit Armut und
Grausamkeit gegenüber allen Lebewesen
lassen ja schon vermuten dass Peter
Kürten auf dunklem Faden wandern wird
aber wie Mirko schon erwähnte 1899
beginnt er seine ersten Diebstahl er
steht nicht irgendwas sondern mag das
Geld eigentlich Lohn für andere Arbeiter
verunrollt er als Lehrling in der
sandformerei wo er den gleichen Beruf
wie sein Vater lernt er hat die Nase
voll von der Willkür und Züchtigung
durch andere Arbeiter
100 Mark sind damals der Monatslohn
eines angesehenen Vorarbeiters also
nicht gerade wenig und damit kann man
schon ordentlich was anstellen
tja und genau das macht Peter Kürten
auch denn der junge Mann ist nicht dumm
und weiß genau dass es eine wichtige
Rolle spielt wie man aussieht und wie
man sich gibt er hat schon einiges
gelesen und kann sich gut ausdrücken er
ist schamant und sieht recht gut aus
mit ein paar neuen Sachen am Leib begibt
er sich auf eine reine Reise zu Schiff
und per Bahn er ist dabei mit einer
Prostituierten unterwegs die er wohl
aushält und mit der er ausgiebig Sex hat
als das Geld verbraucht ist kehrt er
zurück und wird wegen der Unterschlagung
verurteilt er macht Bekanntschaft mit
dem Drill im preußischen Knast und das
gefällt ihm gar nicht
aber nach wenigen Wochen ist er wieder
auf freiem Fuß aber in der Zwischenzeit
hat sich in Peter kürtens Kopf
irgendeinen Schalter umgelegt er spürt
dass er mehr kann als in einer Gießerei
schuften er wird zum in den Tag
hineinlebenden Dandy und wirkt
vermutlich auch interessant auf einige
Frauen
schnell verfällt ihm so auch eine Witwe
mit der er auch von ihr gewünscht
sexuell sadistische Praktiken auslebt
die Tochter der Witwe und die Nachbarn
halten die lautstarken nächtlichen
Handlungen bald nicht mehr aus und so
muss Peter gehen
danach versucht er bei einer alten
Schulfreundin unterzukommen wird aber
von deren Eltern rausgeschmissen da sie
ihn als einen faulen Nichtsnutz ansehen
Peter tingelt fortan zwischen
zechprellereien großen und kleinen
Diebstählen Betrügereien und dem Knast
hin und her
man könnte jetzt meinen war halt so ein
kleiner genove der sich irgendwie
durchschlägt
1904 begehrte auch noch Fahnenflucht um
den preußischen Militär zu entkommen die
Justiz und militärischen Deutschland
versteht da aber gar keinen Spaß der
gerade 20-Jährige geht für sieben Jahre
ins Gefängnis nach eigenen Aussagen hat
er sich dort immer mehr in krasse
tötungs und sexualphantasien
reingesteigert und der Knast ist zu
entkommen
angeblich soll er in Wut Zuständen auch
noch Besuchern der Haftanstalt als das
wilde Tier in Fesseln vorgeführt worden
sein diese Show gibt ihm vermutlich bei
der weiblichen Besucherschaft die
grausige Aufmerksamkeit die er nun mehr
und mehr zu brauchen scheint
tja Peter Kürten ist bald mitnichten nur
ein kleiner Ganove und fahnenflüchtiger
in ihm drin brennt ein Feuer dessen
Flammen schon herauslodern
Peter Kürten ist seit 1904 ein
Brandstifter er zündet wahllos Scheunen
und Schober an er götzt sich dann an dem
Trubel und dem wilden Durcheinander bei
den Löscharbeiten er ist oft mittendrin
hilft aus und der götzt sich dabei am
Leiter Geschädigten wieder und wieder
erregt ihn sein gemeines und kriminelles
tun bis zum Orgasmus oft kehrt er
mehrfach zu den verbrannten Ruinen
zurück drückt sein Bedauern bei den
Menschen vor Ort aus während in ihm eine
perverse Lust kocht
als Peter Kürten 1912 aus dem Gefängnis
kommt beschließt er weiterkriminell zu
sein einen anderen Weg sieht er für sich
und seine Ansprüche nicht er verlegt
sich auf oft lukrative Einbrüche in
Wirtshäuser oder die Wohnungen der
Wirtsleute während dieser Arbeiten
er arbeitet Geld Schmuck und andere
Dinge die sich gut versetzen lassen
1913 bei einem dieser Einbrüche findet
er die Wohnung der Wirtsfamilie klein in
Mülheim seine Heimatstadt nichts wie
erwartet leer vor nein denn in ihrem
Bettchen schläft die kleine zehnjährige
Christine
er hätte einfach gehen können denn der
Einbruch erbrachte keine echte Beute
aber irgendwie zieht es ihn nun zu dem
schlafenden Kind
dann bricht es bei ihm aus er wirkte bis
zur Bewusstlosigkeit bevor er es mit
seinem Taschenmesser brutal ersticht
er hört wieder das blutrauschen und die
Erregung überkommt ihn
Jahrzehnte später wird Peter Kürten
sagen
ich glaube die sicherste Hilfe wäre die
gewesen wenn die Straftat von 1913
entdeckt worden wäre und ich wäre dahin
gerichtet worden
langsam werde ich echt wütend dieser
kleine ganova die niemand ernst nimmt
dieser Typ ist ein Mörder und keiner
sieht was noch kommen wird im Anschluss
an die Tat und voller Erregung fährt
Kürten zurück nach Düsseldorf wenn ich
später attackierte in Gerresheim einen
Mann der auf der Bank sitzt mit einem
geklauten Beil der Mann überlebt zum
Glück Peter Kürten weiß aber nun um
dieses gierige Feuer in ihm und er wird
es noch 17 lange Jahre füttern
ich bin ehrlich gesagt schon langsam
Banger euch zu erzählen was da noch
alles kommt doch erstmal landet der
frische Mörder wieder länger im
Gefängnis und zwar wegen Diebstahls und
weil er sich später an einer
gefängnismeuterei beteiligt hat er sitzt
insgesamt acht weitere Jahre hinter
Gittern
damit ist Kürten beim gewaltigsten töten
jener Zeit nicht dabei er zieht nicht in
den Ersten Weltkrieg und kommt erst 1921
wieder frei dann versucht er einen
Neustart zieht ins thüringische
Altenburg wohl eine seiner verheirateten
Schwestern wohnt und arbeitet in einer
Gießerei
er bleibt bis 1925 sauber wenn man davon
absieht welches Blut ja bereits schon an
seinen Händen klebt
tja und das er bis zu seiner Rückkehr
nach Düsseldorf 1925 frei von Straftaten
bleibt das ist absurderweise einer Frau
und verurteilten Mörderin zu verdanken
Auguste Scharf findet diesen Peter
Kürten der irgendwann in ihrem
Schokoladengeschäft in Altenburg
auftaucht eigentlich nicht sonderlich
sympathisch sie versucht diesen
schmierigen Typen sogar durch verkuppeln
mit einer anderen Frau loszuwerden doch
Peter Kürten ist hartnäckig nach einem
stell Dich ein wo Türken versucht sie
beim Geschlechtsverkehr zu schlagen und
zu würgen weiß sie ihn knallhart in die
Schranken und Kürten
ja er kuscht und ordnet sich ihr
gewissermaßen unter denn was viele in
der Stadt nicht wissen aber er weiß
Auguste ist eine verurteilte Mörderin
die im Affekt ihren zukünftigen und
lange versprochenen Ehemann erschossen
hat
nach dem Zuchthaus um 1915 findet
Augustus scharf schnell wieder ins
normale Leben zurück ein Leben mit
regelmäßiger fleißiger Arbeit ohne
Affären aber nun bald mit Peter Kürten
als Ehemann die beiden heiraten 1923
Peter Kürten sagt später über seine Frau
dann hat meine Frau auch eine gute
unterhaltungsgabe gehabt sie war auch
bewandert auf vielen gebeten außerdem
war sie auch schon etwas gereist hatte
schon was von der Welt gesehen so dass
es immer sehr interessant war jetzt
zuzuhören außerdem hat mir gefallen an
meiner Frau dass sie also im Vergleich
zu mir
gewissermaßen rein war sie konnte nicht
einmal unanständige Gespräche hören oder
dulden sie war weiterhin Ordnungs Leben
fleißig und vor allen Dingen aufrichtig
und ehrlich und hat immerhin in dieser
Zeit in Altenburg auf mich starken
Einfluss ausgeübt
Auguste Kürten wird sich Jahre später so
äußern
daran dass Peter Morde verübt hätte habe
ich zunächst nicht gedacht dazu hatte
ich auch keinen Grund weil ich ja die
mehreren Mädchen mit denen er verkehrt
hatte so weit sie mir bekannt waren
lebend wusste ich habe niemals hier in
Düsseldorf so wenig wie in Altenburg
irgendwas an meinem Manne bemerkt dass
auf einem Mord hingedeutet hätte
das ändert sich auch erst einmal nicht
als beide 1925 nach Düsseldorf ziehen
niemand weiß damals dass Peter Kürten
ein Mörder ist so läuft er immer noch
jungwirkende gepflegte Mann im guten
Anzug durch Düsseldorf stellt Jungfrauen
nach klaut hier und da während seine
Frau fleißig in der Gastronomie arbeitet
und das Geld heranschafft
für die Nachbarn sind die beiden ein
nettes Paar die kleine Wohnung ist
aufgeräumt und der gut aussehende Peter
Kürten immer mit geputzten Schuhen und
Hut holt seine Frau oft von der Arbeit
ab aber dieses Brennen in Peter Kürten
das wird wieder stärker und stärker das
reine Fremdgehen das Schlagen und die
paar sadistischen Praktiken in der Nacht
mit Fremden die können das auch nicht
löschen
all das lässt ihn immer unbefriedigter
zurück das Verlangen wird schließlich so
groß dass es aus ihm herausbricht und
eine Verbrechensserie ohne Gleichen
beginnt
am dritten februar 1929 erwacht erneut
das wahre mörderische Wesen Peter
kürtens jetzt erfahrener geschmeidiger
und zielstrebiger
kurzschlussartig entscheidet er sich die
55-Jährige Apollonia kühn abends auf dem
Weg zu ihrer Wohnung in der bertastraße
anzugreifen er hackt wie wild auf sie
ein die Schafe Schere mit der er
zustecht trifft Sie im Gesicht in die
Hände in die Arme und den Hinterkopf
18 mal bis er zum Orgasmus kommt und die
Frau zusammenbricht dann lässt er von
ihr ab und verschwindet
die Frau überlebt schwer verletzt nur
fünf Tage später zieht es ihn wieder in
den Abendstunden nach draußen
rosa oliger eine achtjährige Schülerin
macht sich am 8 februar 1929 kurz bevor
es dunkel wird von einer Freundin nach
Hause auf doch dort wird sie nie
ankommen
mit vielen Stichwunden mal trittiert mit
Petroleum übergossen und angezündet wird
sie in der Nähe der vinzenzkirche
gefunden
die Leiche ist vollständig bekleidet die
13 Stiche gingen durch den Mantel und
Kleider hindurch wie man später
herausfindet bringt Kürten das Mädchen
um geht dann ins Kino um später mit dem
Petroleum zurückzukehren und sie am
nächsten Morgen anzuzünden
Kürten sagt zu diesem Mord und seine
mehrfachen zurückkommen zum Tatort
später
die Wirkung war in den meisten Fällen
noch intensiver als wie bei der Begehung
der Tat aber auch nicht in allen Fällen
dazu mag beigetragen haben dass sich die
Zeitung meistens da gelesen habe wo sie
ausgehangen waren dass um mich herum
viele Leute standen die sich auch über
die Tat entsetzt
Peter Kürten findet seinen sehr
speziellen Weg für den ultimativen Kick
einen Weg der nur Tod und Leid bringen
wird
ich glaube wir verzichten besser darauf
für jedes seiner Verbrechen die er
darauf von februar 1929 bis Mai 1930
begangen hat im Detail zu beschreiben es
ist wirklich unerträglich aber ich
möchte die Opfer benennen und das
Verbrechen an ihn vielleicht um zu
begreifen dass hier Leben zerstört
wurden und Peter Kürten das für sein
lustig jedes Mal in kaufnamen
Rudolf Scheer 53
Kriegsinvalide am 13 Februar mit 20
scherenstichen getötet
im Juli versucht der Maria Witt und eine
unbekannte junge Frau durch würgen zu
töten beide können sich befreien und
entgehen so mit dem sicheren Tod
am 11 August ersticht Peter Kürten das
Hausmädchen Maria Hahn nachdem sie in
der Nähe eines ausflugslokales
einvernehmlichen Sex im Wald hatten
Kürten befriedigt das nicht und so rammt
er ihr die große Schere in den Hals und
trinkt ihr Blut
ja und das ist einer der Gründe weshalb
der Serienmörder später auch den
Beinamen Vampir von Düsseldorf bekam
gucken selbst sagte dazu Zitat
ich hatte der Hahn zuerst eine
Verletzung am Halse beigebracht aus
dieser Verletzung habe ich Blut in mich
aufgenommen von der Harn größerer Mengen
getrunken
hierbei trat die Auslösung der sexuellen
Erregung ein das getrunkene Blut habe
ich nachher wieder ausgebrochen
[Musik]
danach verscharrte er die Leiche und
kehrte mehrfach an den Tatort zurück um
sich zu befriedigen er schickt sogar
eine Lage Skizze an die Zeitung weil er
sich am Auflauf vergötzen wollte das
funktioniert aber nicht erst Wochen
später wo er eine ähnliche Skizze der
Polizei zu kommen lässt wird ihm dieser
ekelhafte Wunsch erfüllt
Peter Kürten scheint sich nach
Aufmerksamkeit zu sehnen überfällt und
mordet weiter am 21 August sticht er mit
einem Dolch den er sich extra besorgt
hat auf verschiedene Besucher einer
Kirmes ein
Anna Goldhausen Olga Mantel Heinrich
Kornblum werden verletzt Kürten ergötzt
sich an der Panik und dem Auflauf den er
verursacht hat am 24 August 1929 ist
Quitten auf einer weiteren Kirmes in
Flair unterwegs er fängt Luise Lenzen
und Gertrud haarmacher ab luis ist eine
Pflegeschwester und 14 Jahre alt
Gertrud ist fünf Jahre alt und wird von
Luise beaufsichtigt
beide tötet er durch würgen und
Messerstiche in der Nähe einer
Gartensparte nur 200 Meter vom
Elternhaus ger Todes entfernt
am 25 August kurz nach dem Doppelmord an
den Kindern lauert der Mörder der
26-Jährigen Gertrud Schulte auf
als sie sich der Vergewaltigung
wiedersetzt sticht er so wahnsinnig auf
sie ein dass die Spitze des Dolches
abbricht
als er dann befriedigt ist lässt er die
schwerst verwundete Frau liegen und
denkt sie ist tot aber sie überlebt mit
Lähmungen in den Gliedmaßen auch hier
wartet er bis Sanitäter und Polizei
auftauchen was ihn erregt dann werden im
September in kurzer Folge Lina her so
verrückt und Maria Rad angegriffen und
verletzt alle können fliehen Kürten wird
gestört und verschwindet
am 30 September 1929 vergewaltigt Peter
Kürten Ida Reuter und tötet sie brutal
mit unzähligen Hammerschlägen auf den
Kopf
ebenfalls mit einem Hammer tötet der
Vampir von Düsseldorf die 22-Jährige
Elisabeth Düringer am 12 oktober 1929
die beiden Frauen Hubertine Meurer und
klarer Wanders werden am 25 oktober 1929
Opfer der hammerschläger von Peter
Kürten beide haben aber Glück Kürten
wird gestört die Frauen von Passanten
gefunden und ins Krankenhaus gebracht
Mirko kannst du bitte weitermachen
na klar
die Polizei in Düsseldorf ermittelt
fieberhaft es werden auch Spezialisten
wieder berühmte Kommissar Ernst gennad
aus Berlin hinzugezogen sogar Edgar
Wallace der britische Krimiautor bietet
seine Hilfe an man weiß nun dass die
Taten zusammenhängen und man es mit
einem Serientäter zu tun hat
es wird das erste Mal in der deutschen
Geschichte auch ein Täterprofil damals
von Kriminaldirektor Gacy erstellt die
Stadt ist in Panik überall könnte der
Tod lauern und das tut er auch am 7
november 1929 verschwindet abends die
fünfjährige Gertrud albermann das
Mädchen spielte vorher am Geschäft ihrer
Pflegeeltern in der Ackerstraße
eine Nachbarin beobachtet wie das
Mädchen mit einem gepflegten Mann
mitgeht und denkt sich nicht viel dabei
weil Gertrud lacht mein fataler Fehler
am folgenden Samstag den 9 November
findet eine Polizeistreife die Leiche
Gertrud albermanns getötet mit 34
Messerstichen und Verletzungen der
Geschlechtsteile um noch Sperma
sicherstellt
Peter Kürten scheint seinen Weg mit
diesem Mord gefunden zu haben er sagt
später aus
ich meinte bedeutend leichter geworden
zu sein vom Körpergewicht 50 und
abgenommen zu haben ich habe ferner hin
frei atmen können und auch keine
Beschwerden auf der Brust und auf dem
Kopf und im Kopf für mehr gespürt
sondern mich freie und wirklich wohl
dabei gefunden und habe mir lebhaft
ausgemalt wie das was mich vorher
körperlich bedrückt hat jetzt auf die
übergehen würde die damit daran schuldig
waren
bitte was was für ein Kranker
durchgeknallter widerlicher Typ der
macht jetzt auch noch andere für sein
Verhalten schuldig ja und er zieht
weiter eine Spur der Gewalt hinter sich
her am 7 dezember 1929 findet der
geflügelwerte des Hofgartens Matthias
Weyer Graf den Kadaver eines Schwans der
besonders zutraulich zu Menschen war der
Hals des Tieres ist wie mit einem sehr
scharfen Messer durchtrennt aber
nirgendwo ist Blut zu sehen vor Gericht
sagte der Tierwärter aus Zitat
ich habe die ganze Umgebung bis zum
Wasser hin abgesucht aber keine Spur von
Blut gefunden ich muss annehmen dass
derjenige der das Tier getötet hat das
Blut ausgezogen hat
[Musik]
und das hat Peter Kürten auch sein
Beiname der Vampir von Düsseldorf wird
zu seinem Synonym
dann wird es etwas ruhiger um den Mörder
die Ehefrau von Peter Kürten bekommt
langsam mit dass etwas nicht stimmen
kann Blut auf der Kleidung ständig ist
der Mann nachts weg aber sie redet sich
die Situation schön verweist nur ab und
zu die Affären die Türken mit in die
gemeinsame Wohnung bringt das Hauses und
weint sich bei den Nachbarn aus weil der
Mann untreu ist
Kürten verlegt seine brutalen
Aktivitäten wieder ins Freie er versucht
bei den Frauen Hildegard Eid Marianne
del Santo
Irma Becker einem unbekannten Mädchen
aus Herne Frau hau Charlotte Ulrich
Gertrud Bell und sibilia will irgendwie
zum Zug zu kommen
zum Glück wird keine von ihnen getötet
dennoch werden einige der Frauen brutal
misshandelt und schwer verletzt
die 30-jährige Frau how versucht Kürten
zu vergewaltigen und schlägt sie die
Frau sagt später aus
er sagte mir dass sei nun der Dank dafür
dass er mich mit ins Café genommen hätte
ich gab ihm drei Mark worauf er mir
zweimal 15 zurückgab er küsste mir das
Blut vom Mund er wollte mich noch weiter
anhalten ich lief aber fort er rief mir
noch nach du kannst froh sein dass wir
nicht allein im Hofgarten sind
das alles und wie muss ich mir diese
Zeit vorstellen so viele alleinstehende
Frauen ich meine ich kann mir das nur
mit den fehlenden Männern nach dem
Ersten Weltkrieg erklären die Polizei
hat weiter im Dunkeln macht
Gegenüberstellung aber auf Peter Kürten
der ja sonst nicht straffällig wird
kommt keiner der Ermittler
aber nun passiert etwas das alles ändert
am 14 mai 1930 kommt die Wohnungslose
Maria bootlies von Köln nach Düsseldorf
und wird von einem Mann am Bahnhof
angesprochen er bietet ihr ein
Schlafplatz an
Peter Kürten beobachtet das und folgt
den beiden
als der andere Mann zu dringlich wird
gibt Kürten den Retter und bietet
seinerseits Unterkunft und bleibe an
Peter Kürten bringt sie in seine Wohnung
in der Mettmanner Straße 71 wo sie gegen
23 Uhr ankommen dort fühlt sich Maria
Buddies aber nicht wohl und Kürten
bietet ihr darauf eine andere Unterkunft
an sie gehen einen Umweg durch die
sogenannte Wolfsschlucht er wirkt sie
küsst sie dann und drängt sie zum Sex
dann bringt er sie zur Straßenbahn und
beobachtet sie weiter Maria budlies
landet schließlich im gertrudisheim von
dort aus schreibt sie einer bekannten
Frau Brückner einen Brief in welchem sie
das Geschehen der Nacht schildert
am 14 mai 1930 ist Maria budlies so fast
ein weiteres Opfer Peter krückens
geworden
sie schrieb ein Frau Brückner dass sie
vermutlich diesem Serienmörder den
Vampir begegnet ist
der Brief kommt aber nie bei der
Adressatin an zum Glück sondern landet
wegen eines Fehlers bei einer Frau
Brückmann die auch in derselben Straße
wohnt die liest ihn und alarmiert die
Polizei die Polizei schafft ist Maria
Bud lies ausfindig zu machen und diese
führt die Beamten am 21 mai 1930 zu
Peter und Auguste kürtenswohnung Peter
Kürten beobachtet das Geschehen und
zählt eins und eins zusammen jetzt wird
es eng für ihn
die Polizei sieht wieder ab aber Maria
bodies geht aus Neugier noch mal zu dem
Haus als sie dort auf Kürten trifft
erschreckt sie aber nichts passiert
Peter Kürten spürt dass er verloren hat
und er öffnet in einem halben Geständnis
an seine Frau Auguste dass er notsucht
mit einer Frau betrieben hätte und sich
aber wegen seiner Vorstrafen nicht mehr
hier blicken lassen darf
Auguste Kürten hilft Ihrem Mann ein
Zimmer in der Adlerstraße zu mieten sie
ahnt noch nichts vom wahren Ausmaß
seiner Verbrechen
das Peter kürten die Lage richtig
eingeschätzt hat zeigt sich sofort denn
es gibt am nächsten Tag schon eine
Hausdurchsuchung bei den kürtens die
erfolglos bleibt
aber Auguste erfährt so dass die Polizei
nach dem Vampir von Düsseldorf sucht und
nicht nur nach einem Vergewaltiger
nachdem die Beamten die Wohnung
verlassen haben erscheint Peter Kürten
der alles beobachtet hat
dann gibt er auf und sagt zu seiner Frau
na ja ich habe es getan ich habe alles
getan
aber Auguste weiß erstmal gar nicht was
er meint die beiden verabreden sich zum
Essen und dort erzählt er seiner Frau
alles über seine Morde und Verbrechen
Auguste selbst verurteilte Mörderin
bricht zusammen und bietet ihm an sich
mit ihm gemeinsam umzubringen
aber Kürten ist feige und Bazis nun kann
er bald die Aufmerksamkeit aller
bekommen er wird die Presse bestimmen
und wochenlang in aller Munde sein aber
stellen will er sich nicht seine Frau
soll das Kopfgeld bekommen quasi als
Unterhalt für die Zukunft und dass sie
ihn ausliefert man weiß übrigens bis
heute nicht ob sie die Summe jemals
bekommen hat
bei einem weiteren Treffen mit seiner
Frau hat diese vorher die Polizei
informiert und so wird Peter Kürten am
24 mai 1930 um 15 Uhr am Rochusmarkt in
Düsseldorf überwältigt und verhaftet es
hat nun ein Ende
nach 14 Tagen sind die
kriminalpolizeilichen Vernehmungen mit
Kürten abgeschlossen es war keine
siebenmonatige Voruntersuchung in der
Kürten von Ärzten begutachtet wird
sechs Wochen lang wird er in der
Irrenanstalt bedburg-how medizinischen
Untersuchungen unterzogen Peter Kürten
genießt die allgegenwärtige
Aufmerksamkeit schreibt sich sogar noch
mehr Straftaten zu dir als
Minderjähriger verübt haben will er sagt
zu den Vernehmungen
überhaupt diese polizeilichen Protokolle
die enthalten auch manches was nicht so
in allen Punkten meine persönliche
Wiedergabe gewesen wäre wissen sie dass
ging nachher schon so ein bisschen nach
schemaf und man hat das schon so
gewissermaßen ins humoristische
hineingezogen wenn ich das immer
wiederholte und der Beamte der da an der
Schreibmaschine saß der konnte sehr
schnell schreiben ein Kriminalbeamter
der sagte in den meisten Fällen zu mir
na Peter wir taufen wir das Kind nächste
Nummer
denn ich habe so den Eindruck bekommen
von denen als ob die auf dem Standpunkt
standen man muss das Eisen schmieden
solange es noch warm ist das müssen Sie
nicht alles so wörtlich nehmen ich habe
mir da was drauf eingebildet dass da so
viel Wesens gemacht wurde ich habe
gehört wie die Rede davon war die
Unterredung stattfand mit französischen
zeitungsberichterstattern schicken sie
gleich Bild mit Flugzeug großes Honorar
und alles hat mich da auf dem
Polizeipräsidium angestaunt
gewissermaßen als wundert hier
aber alles was die Polizei heraus
bekommt ist grausam genug und schon so
schwer zu verkraften es braucht keine
Ausschmückung
die Bevölkerung nimmt die Nachrichten
von dem Fall begierig auf es inspiriert
sogar den Regisseur Fritz Lang zu seinem
ersten Tonfilm m eine Stadt sucht einen
Mörder
heute würde man von den famous 15
sprechen doch Kürten ist ein
Massenmörder das Gericht erkennt ihn
nach den Untersuchungen durch die Ärzte
als vollschuldfähig und die
Gerichtsverhandlung werden durchgezogen
Zitat die Taten kürtens stellen sich uns
also in der Weise da zum Zweck der
sexuellen Befriedigung hat Kürten seine
Taten geplant unternommen und
durchgeführt die sexuelle Befriedigung
war von ihm nur durch Gewalttaten
vollendet möglich
die in der Sühne Idee von ihm
zusammengefasste denkerische Theorie
ermöglichte es ihm jede Hemmung beiseite
zu schieben die nach einer Tat für die
nächste Tat entstehen konnte Großmann
sucht und Fantasie Ausmalung gaben ihm
zu den Gesamtheit gegen das affektive
beharren
das Urteil ergeht auch bald ein
Gnadengesuch wird abgelehnt und so kommt
der Tag der Todesstrafe für 9 Morde und
32 Mordversuche immer näher am 2 juli
1931 saust das Feuerball um kurz nach 6
Uhr am Morgen hinab und der eigens aus
Magdeburg angereist des schafrichter
stellt den Tod des mördersfest
wieder einer dieser extremen Fälle
spüre da jede Menge Wut und Trauer wir
wollten ja eigentlich nur über diese
Fälle berichten aber dass dieser Karl
einfach keine Reue zeigt bist du das
macht mich sprachlos und wütend dieser
Typ ist ein echter Soziopath dem anderen
Menschen absolut gleichgültig sind
Natalie wie sieht's bei dir aus was
macht diese Geschichte mit dir ich bin
angewidert erschrocken ich war auch
zwischenzeitlich verängstigt weil er
wird ja nicht der einzige sein der diese
Gedanken in seinem Kopf hat ja also man
muss davon ausgehen dass es immer noch
Menschen gibt die draußen auf der Straße
freier rumlaufen und den vielleicht auch
dieses feiern oder hat ja manche
Geschichten die sind einfach so düster
die kann sich kein Horror aus verbesser
ausdenken
dennoch Kürten wir ein Kind seiner Zeit
und seiner Umstände in der Familie und
der Gesellschaft der Knast hat es ja
sicher auch nicht besser gemacht und die
kriegswelt am Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts
war fürchterlich hat auch also nicht
geholfen Peter gehört nun zum Glück eine
Ausnahme zumindest was die Ausführung
seiner Tat eingeht was ich nur grausam
fand war sein Resümee keine Reue also
wirklich auch wenn er bittende Briefe an
die Verwandten der Opfer vor seiner
Hinrichtung geschrieben hat also ich
glaube nicht dass der da irgendetwas
ernst gemeint hat von seinen
Entschuldigung dann hast du vollkommen
recht glaubwürdig ist das auf keinen
Fall oh jetzt zeigt er keine in kürtens
Worten
ich hatte eigentlich dauernd die
Stimmung sie werden es drang nennen zum
umbringen je mehr um so lieber ich habe
nicht die Mittel dazu gehabt hätte dann
hätte ich ganze Massen umgebracht und
Katastrophen herbeigeführt
er wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich so
manche Menschen wollen die Welt einfach
brennen sehen
wir danken euch fürs Zuhören
ich muss noch ein wenig nachdenken aber
ich danke euch auch dass ihr dabei wart
bis bald euer Mirko und eure Natalie
den Fall Peter Kürten erzählen wir unter
anderem mit Hilfe der Faktensammlung des
Blogs Vampir von Düsseldorf in dem der
Autor Quellen aus unterschiedlicher
Fachliteratur zum Fall verwendet aus der
wir zitieren Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
und Antonia Haier Produktion Marvin
schwarz